Thinking like Uncle G aka Google. As I've said before in a previous video, the more that
we can put ourselves in Google's shoes, the more we can understand what benefits them
and what they're trying to accomplish, the better job we can do at SEO. So I want to
have you guys just think about something really quick and maybe it's something you've asked
yourself before. Maybe it's not. But I want you to ask yourself this question. It's a
rhetorical question. How does Google actually make money? We see them all over. We know
they're worth billions and billions of dollars. They might even be worth a trillion at this
point. I don't even know. They make phones. I mean, it's such a big company. It's such
a popular thing that it's a verb now. Like, did you Google it? It's actually a verb. But
how do they make money? What is their main revenue source? Well, I'm going to give you
the answer, and that is through this little thing called AdWords, which all of us are
familiar with because we've all dealt with it. We've all spent money on it. We've all
used it and abused it, et cetera. And so the reason I'm bringing that up is you then need
to ask yourself, okay, well, how does AdWords work? Why does AdWords work? Well, AdWords
works because so many people go to Google. They have so many searches that they can charge
for it. Well, why do they have so many searches? Okay, we're just going down the rabbit hole,
but think about it. If you have a question, if you're looking for concrete, if you're
looking to extend your pool deck or you're looking to put in a sidewalk or you're looking
to pour a pad for your basketball hoop for your kid or whatever, right, what are you
going to do? You're going to go to Google and you're going to search concrete contractors
near me or concrete contractors Las Vegas, Nevada or concrete contractors St. George,
right? Why? Because in the past, every time you've searched anything, Google has given
you results that are very, very accurate and they almost know exactly what you're looking
for. And we have gotten so accustomed to, if we have a question, we don't even need
to really type it in correctly. We can honestly just type in a part of a lyric or somebody's
name that's spelled incorrectly or somebody is famous plus their husband and it will pull
it up. Their search engine is so good and is so accurate that we have relied on Google
to answer all of our questions. But for Google to keep charging exorbitant amounts of money
like they do for AdWords, that has to stay true. What does all this mean, Nick? What
this means is Google needs us as customers to trust them. And so they need to put the
top, the people that they put at the top of Google in the maps, in the organic and even
in the ads, they have to be relevant to what people are looking for, aka they need to get
their questions answered. Okay? So what I just need you to wrap your head around is
as you're doing SEO, as you're doing content, as you're doing your ads, as you're doing
everything related to Google, keep in mind how Google makes money. And think about it
as you go to put something on your website, ask yourself is this related to somebody that's
searching for concrete contractors? Would they also search this thing? Somebody that's searching
concrete contractors is probably also searching for how much does concrete cost? Can you pour
concrete in the cold? Top rated concrete contractors near me, concrete company, right? And there's
all these different things that are related to it. So let's use another example, right?
People that are searching for Kanye West, and I'm using him because right now he's getting
blown up in the media, so it's on top of everybody's minds, okay? If you're, somebody or you that's
searching for Kanye West is also probably searching for other things, right? They might
be searching for Kanye's net worth. They might be searching for Yeezy's. They might be searching
for Kim, right? They might be searching for some crazy comment that he made. And so the
companies that understand this, the companies that write the blog articles and the regular
articles and the pages that talk about all of those things that are the most authoritative
around that subject matter are the ones that are going to win. So when we're doing sites
and we're doing content and we're doing our on page SEO, which we're going to get into
all that, I just need your frame of mind realizing that we need to be the most authoritative.
We need to be all encompassing. If we're talking about concrete contractors, we also need to
be talking about concrete companies. We also need to be talking about concrete cost. That's
why we do the keyword list so thoroughly. And there are some things we don't care about
ranking for, right? We don't care about cheap concrete near me because those are not customers
that we want. But I just want you guys, as you're going through this, if you can drill
this into your head and every time you're about to put something on your page or choose
an anchor text, which all these terms I'm going to get into. If you don't know what
somebody is talking about, it's coming. But I'm just giving you a little precursor. Just
think like Google. Think like Uncle G and for them to continue to charge for ads, which
is their main revenue stream, they have to continue to be trusted. And the way that they
are trusted is because when you search something, they put results at the top that answer your
questions.